[Music]  [Applause]  some people need move on but about us  let us stay on  hey miss Potts if you find this  recording don't feel bad about this part  of the journey use the end  [Music]  just for the record being adrift in  space with zero promise of rescue is  more fun that sounds food and water ran  out four days ago  boxers going out tomorrow morning I've  been when I drift off I will dream bet  you it's always you  [Music]  [Music]  a nose did exactly what he said he was  gonna do  you're wiped out 50% of all living  creatures  we lost all of us  we lost friends who lost family  you lost a part of ourselves  this is the fight of our lives this is  gonna mark Steve I know it is cuz I  don't know what I'm gonna do if it  doesn't  hi is anyone home this is Scott Lang we  met a few years ago at the airport in  Germany my job really big is just an old  message I know you know that's Center  that's me can you buzz me in  [Music]